hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dead-end Road now I
didn't want to leave it at just that I
wanted to finish this game and a lot of
you guys said that one of the things
that I was missing was that I wasn't
buying medication to make the Phantom's
go away which was an important mechanic
for me to get through this and get to
the end of the goddamn road and get my
[ __ ] wish granted I don't even
remember what my wish was but I'm gonna
get a granted if I seem very serious
it's because I'm not so shut up hi
Graham haha doing okay bye bye bye bye
also I got a gamepad this time so should
be much better when I'm going down the
road shut up grandma yeah oops
[ __ ] huh what the [ __ ] I'm not doing
that stop it not that stop okay
something's happened horrible there we
go
I got it anyway bye sure default that
wasn't boo who wanted to go I don't know
why but now we're gonna get on this road
and we're gonna get to the end of this
what do I request some of the dark
powers big penis
the doctors have not understood your
request well let me spell it out for you
he's cork what you got haha you
understand I want a huge cork thank you
very much
hi buddy
alrighty then really a mine well let me
tell you something about myself hmm
alright so I need a candle a bell in a
book candle the bell in the book can the
belly look in a band like handle about
Allah book least I could honk this time
that's nice
wait this sucks I didn't mean to do that
that wasn't me
I forgot how slow I actually need to
take this because apparently going fast
on this road is just suicide put a baby
there who put on AB [ __ ] this yeah that
ain't gonna work
yeah that's what I thought I'm a restart
that did not go well for me let's try
again it's just a slow slog who put
boxes in the middle of goddamn Road it's
not my fault is Road randomly changes
directions lay a whip and tentacle a
whipping tentacle you know whipping back
and forth goddamnit
not today not today here we go why um ok
we made it into town and hopefully it's
gonna have a lot of our stool and I'm
not gonna go into that alleyway and get
robbed again scented candle dictionary
matches probably good scented candle
what what ah I don't know why the
controls are all janked up like that now
though I've been fighting that this
whole time I have no idea all right so
matches I imagine are what I need to
light the candle that's like a little
unknown
dictionary that's expensive MA
all right fine then goodbye so I don't
need anything yet from the medicinal
shop at least I don't think so I'm not
gonna worry about that just now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna keep going and
then all I need left is a bell and then
save the rest of my money for what I
need and maybe a repair if I need it I
don't know I'm not I never said sure ah
[ __ ] me god damn it
those that was that was an overreaction
that shouldn't have got me that way yeah
[ __ ] not this again someone get the
windshield wipers Olo whoa hello
what the [ __ ] you can't throw both of
those at me at the same time I was at a
standstill how was I gonna react there
was no time to go not today
see I can I can deal with all this other
stuff because I can just I get it just
basically go to crawl but if a car comes
at me it's like nothing I can do
Hey
it's a ghost it was something actually
spooky was the antique store get votive
candle collar Bell that'll do that's a
cheap one
boink okay so I got a I got matches I
got a book that candle scented one that
was a votive candle oh god I gotta hit
no yeah okay good got that got the Bell
wait did I get the Bell
I think I already had the bell but I
just want to make sure I don't want to
leave that to chance I can't remember
cuz it's random cycling [ __ ] thing
okay so this is where things are gonna
get interesting what I'm gonna do
maybe I can get a pack of cigarettes or
something that'll calm this guy's nerves
I don't know definitely not gonna buy
scratch cards five bucks [ __ ]
reduces stress by a small amount okay
but chocolate is chocolate dude alright
why not I'm very stressed mm okay we're
gonna see how that does chocolate and
cigarettes nothing better
does he does he want me flung bed
perhaps broiled perhaps put on a spit
right through my butt with an apple in
my mouth that's a lot of people on the
internet like me I'm not complaining
okay we made it in the next one that
actually was a lot more manageable I
think the soda in the or the chocolate
and the other one but luckily in this
place there's a pharmacy but let me say
what's in here just in case I mean I
don't know if the Bible would be better
than the dictionary math textbook how
much is the Bible let me make sure that
I don't press No okay let me just go see
what all the stuff is at the pharmacy
first and then I'm gonna see if I need
to buy the Bible because this is one
more thing till the dead-end road so
come on baby give me the drugs give me
the Drew's health check is that free
stress reading a dangerously high level
oh my god how do I get out of that there
we go let's see diazepam Miami okay all
right so what's my stress level now doc
worryingly high quaaludes Oh fully
reduces all stress okay
boink okay I'm good this can be aren't I
ah I'm perfectly safe haha alright so
let me uh because there's nothing else
to buy in my cars in great shape I can
just make sure and get this Bible just
in case you know you never know with
these things cuz I got a bow and I got a
Bible and I got a scented candle ever
hang on by good everything gonna be good
let's get out here I can't wait for this
nice relaxing drive all the way to
dead-end Road it's gonna be wonderful
and nothing is gonna go wrong and I'm
two days from retirement
not even three it's gonna be good I'm
retiring tomorrow with my huge cork
please just make sure ya dead-end road
boo doink oh man there's gonna be such a
good Drive so
farts not completely insane Oh whoo
goddamn that was close I guess I still
have to worry about there's a lot of
oncoming traffic and that's not good
how much appreciate it well it's a ghost
let's go yeah geez oh come on oh there
was no way to avoid that are you [ __ ]
kidding me
are you [ __ ] with me
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] there was no way
to avoid that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
god damn it that sucks it's not my fault
oh all right
wax candl I'll take it yeah a Travel
Guide that sounds nice and cheap yeah
and firelighter seven bucks fine
whatever I don't care it all evens out
to about the same price and I just need
a bell
much I think what I need to do to stay
in the game on that last row DS I have
to stay in the middle even if it means
I'm gonna hit a pothole but I can't hit
every pothole
yeah whatever I'll figure it out
what what do what is this [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what it was this [ __ ] what whose is
it I could do it was a baby in the
middle of the road I couldn't do
anything it was pride just one of those
things where I couldn't avoid it it's
actually a psychological thing and not
actually real I don't know whatever
stupid yes stupid yes dumb is Geum oh
god I'm in the demons butthole now well
poop me out already jeez what do you got
for me give me a bell give me an antique
Bell one as old as your grandma
it's a grimoire broken Bell is it yes
fall missing its clapper
that sounds useless to me grimoire sure
sounds better than what I had before I'm
not gonna buy a broken Bell I don't know
if he's even matter well I'm gonna get
it cuz four bucks just in case but I'll
get a better Bell later on if I need to
which I don't know if I need to but I'll
get one yeah I have a funny feeling
better I'm changing up how oh I'm
changing up how I'm driving to involve a
lot more braking because I have a funny
feeling this is how the row the game was
meant to be played you're supposed to
break in response to you know threats
and not just go 20 miles an hour down
the road because that's a douchey way of
playing and I ain't a douche why I'm a
dude ray but I'm a deuce it's gonna
survive with braking like normal drivers
do in their human cars ah
alright last stop before the end of the
road let's get some quaaludes yes please
bonk cowbell I like the sound of that
I love a good cowbell uh I wonder if
there's anything I can do forget
probably not All Things Considered I
think I have enough gas to get back but
might as well spend my money somehow
damn it nan enough cash upgrades I can't
afford any of this how do you get more
money alright now you're goddamn it how
do i no no stop it
what no no what the [ __ ] let me leave
let me [ __ ] leave [ __ ] let me
leave let me [ __ ] leave what the [ __ ]
oh no come on come on
[ __ ] me what the [ __ ]
I can't leave it won't leave this
[ __ ] screen because it's been bugged
like that since I started playing I
didn't know that it would [ __ ]
oh oh oh oh my goodness gracious
all I had to do is alt-tab out of it and
hopefully you didn't mess up the
recording but with my good new recording
style it should be a-okay I'm pissed I'm
so mad
once Umayyad don't mess me I'm worried I
needed to take an angry sip of water
now here we go I'm not gonna go ask
crazy on this next road because
obviously it's the dangerous road but
here we go try to stay in the middle as
best I can the problem is there's no
middle line is the main deal here I'm
watching [ __ ] what is that what is what
is that that's new
I haven't seen that before ok ok hello I
just saw your show you did awesome
good job random dead tours Oh in the
middle of the [ __ ] Road [ __ ] man woof
woof woof woof woof woof woof woof
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh my god I want
to get off mr. bones wild ride
well that's not helpful stop throwing
your [ __ ] faces at me they're all
ugly
all of them every one of them [ __ ]
bird okay that's I need I needed that I
needed that oh Jesus God so close it's
cotton it's so close hello oh god oh god
oh god where am i where am I why can't I
[ __ ] man holy [ __ ] that was like
unturned a bowl oh [ __ ] where do I go ah
oh jeez and Zod seasons I don't like
that
okay car
it's a raining blood I think it might be
starting to rain blood I thought I saw a
drizzle blood slightly the chances
partly cloudy with a stream of blood
ah [ __ ] don't do that
[ __ ] come on now
no not yet doing all right so far the
road straighten out oh no like this we
all don't like it still recording I'm
looking for something to go wrong ten a
road
well every one of you legion sons of
[ __ ] can line up to suck my balls cuz
I'm about to win
any minute now I'm just scared to keep
going forward but I did it I did it good
yes yes yes did i do hi grandma hi I
sure did it was a son of a [ __ ] and a
half but you know all about that grandma
I'm surprised very few make it this far
I know grabba but I'm skilled you poor
naive fool many years ago I to perform
the ritual oh but I was lucky I was able
to bargain for my soul on condition that
I continued the curse okay and lure more
unsuspecting lambs into the waiting arms
of my master judge me no child you would
have done the same but enough talk
did you bring the required items yes do
I get my huge cork show me what you have
I have a lot of stuff I see an excellent
selection you have your indeed it seems
you may still have a chance I got the
right stuff you what go now and complete
the ritual ooh there is still a chance
to save yourself to save yourself from
my master okay thanks grandma
grandma's a little loopy oh [ __ ] what do
I do I don't know what to do what am i
what
Oh what the [ __ ] Oh God well it's it's
not moving what the [ __ ] it's yeah and
move you [ __ ] why is it not moving it's
not moving what the [ __ ]
move what are you doing what are you
doing oh that's right I gotta hold it
down oh you are joking me oh you are
[ __ ] with me
[ __ ] it that is a load of [ __ ] that
is a load of oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] off
son of a piece of beaver [ __ ] I'm not
doing it again
okay that is the end of dead-end Road
I'm not doing it again I got to an
ending if you want to see the real
ending you can play for yourself but I'm
not gonna go through that again
I've spent way too much time trying to
get to the end of this and I got there
and just because it was a dill weed
doesn't mean that I'm also going to weed
Dill's so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye-bye
Oh